madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer neuf jours de
négociations pour sortir la côte
d'ivoire de la crise
les discussions ont débuté aujourd'hui à
marcoussis ce près de paris un policier
a été tué à l'armé blanche et quatre
autres blessés lors d'une interpellation
dans la sphère de la ricine la
grande-bretagne est sous le choc
enfin l'or pour carole montillet super
géant de cortina d'ampezzo elle s'impose
sur l'api où son ami régine cavagnoud
avait gagné la descente il ya tout juste
deux ans
c'est la table ronde de la dernière
chance tous les acteurs de la crise en
côte d'ivoire le reconnaissent les
négociations ont débuté aujourd'hui
pendant neuf jours personne ne sortira
du centre de marcoussis ce un premier
espoir de règlement donc après quatre
mois de crise profonde
nora boubetra denis bassompierre
marcoussis ce petit village de 7000
habitants au sud de paris
c'est ici que va se jouer l'avenir de la
côte d'ivoire
derrière les grilles du centre national
de rugby à l'abri des regards
le projet est ambitieux les délégations
ont neuf jours pour mettre fin à une
crise qui dure depuis maintenant quatre
mois tout a commencé ce matin au centre
de conférence international
le premier rendez vous avec la paix a
lieu à partir autour de la table j'ai
freiné les uns à côté des autres
gouvernements principaux partis
politiques qui les trois mouvements
rebelles
dès l'ouverture de la conférence
dominique de villepin donne le ton et
rappelle à chacun ses responsabilités
sur des principes clairs pensons
aujourd'hui et demain à la côte d'ivoire
et aux ivoiriens
nous n'avons pas vous n'avez pas le
droit de les décevoir
la france veut à tout prix éviter une
guerre civile généralisée lui aussi misé
sur la médiation de la france henri
konan bédié l'ancien président ivoirien
ne s'était pas exprimé depuis 99 date à
laquelle il avait été chassé du pouvoir
par un push
la tipp ou simplement à cela que les
gens des régions qui est confiant ce
médiateur et la france est l'amie des
peuples à plus tard la france
puissance dans les couloirs il ya là
aussi un autre revenant l'opposant
alassane ouattara ancien premier
ministre que certains journaux abidjan
accuse de soutenir les rebelles et
menacé de mort il vit en exil en france
il faut que la paix revienne et à
l'issue de cela il faut maintenant de
nouvelles élections présidentielles de
nouvelles élections législatives pour
que ce pays démarre sur des rails de
bonne gouvernance et de totale
démocratie ne sont pas d'accord ce sont
les supporters du président ivoirien
laurent gbagbo
pas question pour eux de convoquer de
nouvelles élections et ils le font
savoir aux délégations présentes
voilà qui augure mal des pourparlers de
paris le peuple ivoirien espère beaucoup
de cette négociation qui se joue en
france la table ronde est à la une de
tous les journaux et on imagine à quel
point la tente est grande après cette
longue période de crise le reportage à
abidjan de nos envoyés spéciaux
robert et georges mines angoy beaucoup
d'abidjanais s'intéressait ce matin au
titre de la presse à la une des journaux
ivoiriens
la table ronde de paris une conférence
de la paix qui stigmatise des opinions
nous qui donnons raison d'un sujet nous
souhaitons que à la sortie de cette
conférence qui leur trouve une solution
adaptée et et cette guerre farid
commence à en avoir marre l'on peut
régler les problèmes qui aujourd'hui se
passe dans le pays afin que nous les
ivoiriens n'auraient toujours la paire
nous ne sommes pas habitués à la guerre
le dialogue à paris ne sera pas chose
facile car ici les gens ne se parlent
plus
il savait qu on parle de nationalisme et
d'ingérence française d'un pays dans le
monde qui a plus de 20 sites pour faire
de travailler sur son sol vous êtes
méchant méchant vous l'avez au pied
voici lancé vous descendez de l'avion où
passe le français est différent parce
que tu es pouvoir on considère la
conférence de paris comme une solution
possible mais pas ultime
le président gbagbo n'entend pas faire
de concessions je pense que abb ont eu
tort de prendre les armes
c'est à ceux qui ont tant qu'on doit
demander de revenus dans l'égalité ce
sens qu'elle plongeait de la discussion
le dialogue à paris se présente comme un
exercice difficile difficile non
seulement pour les ivoiriens mais
également pour la france
car si la conférence de paris échoue il
n'y aura pas d'autre issue que le retour
à un conflit armé
c'est annoncé comme la troisième vague
d'interpellations dans la sphère de la
ricine mais l'opération a très vite
tourné au drame
un policier a été tué à l'armé blanche
et quatre autres ont été blessées la
nuit dernière à manchester sophie
guillaume stephen hawke avait 40 ans il
était père de trois enfants
hier soir dans cette maison de
manchester il a été poignardé à mort le
policier participait à une opération
antiterroriste en compagnie de ses
collègues il venait d'arrêter trois
hommes et s'apprêtaient à fouiller les
lieux
alors que la perquisition se mettait en
place
l'un des suspects a réussi à se libérer
il a saisi un couteau de cuisine et a
attaqué plusieurs policiers
malheureusement l'un d'eux est mort de
ses blessures
une enquête a été ouverte pour tenter de
comprendre comment le suspect âgé de 27
ans non menotté a bien pu échapper à la
vigilance de ses gardiens aujourd'hui à
manchester comme dans tout le pays
le drame provoque une immense émotion le
premier ministre lui même a tenu à
rendre hommage au policier décédé
c'était un bon père de famille et un
très bon officier de police
nous pleurons sa disparition avant de la
mordre à nous renforcer dans notre
détermination à éradiquer le terrorisme
sous toutes ses formes
l'opération de cette nuit était liée à
l' enquête menée après la découverte de
ricine dans cet appartement du nord de
londres
la ricine un poison extrêmement violents
susceptibles d'être utilisés comme armes
de destruction massive par des terreaux
toute la nuit
et encore ce matin les enquêteurs ont
cherché des traces de ce produit dans la
maison de manchester
il ne semblait pas en avoir trouvé quant
aux trois terroristes présumés tous
trois d'origine nord africaine
ils ont été entendus toute la journée
par les policiers en france les anciens
beaux parents d'abderrazak besseghir ont
été mises en examen aujourd'hui et
écroués dans le même temps le bagagiste
de roissy retournait pour la première
fois à l'aérogare sont battus lui a été
rendu il va pouvoir reprendre le travail
sandrine haram ans libérée depuis
vendredi s'est entouré de ses amis quête
d razak besseghir reprend enfin le
chemin de l'aéroport de roissy le
bagagiste est sur le point de retrouver
son honneur son travail
comment ça revient dans le cours normal
de la vie quoi l'entretien avec la
police de l'air et des frontières durera
quelques minutes à sa sortie mais c'est
dire retrouve son badge d'accès aux
avions un retour à la normale sans
rancune et compatit cinq ans c'est que
je pense qu'ils font leur travail voire
tout simplement ce que c'est dur de
poids de juger mes dents on a un temps
limite savoir gilles justement si
j'arrêtais vraiment attendre ils ont été
vaincus les faits
au même moment l'histoire s'accélère au
tribunal de bobigny les anciens beaux
parents du bagagiste sont entendus et
finalement écroué en fin d'après midi le
juge des libertés a décidé de les mettre
sous mandat de dépôt tous les deux
monsieur va être incarcéré à villepinte
et madame à fleury mérogis les raisons
de la machination présumée ourdi par le
couple bechiri c'est la mort brutale de
leur fille dans un incendie en juillet
dernier un drame dont il tenait pour
responsable besseghir il faut que cet
homme et cette femme dans la proportion
de leurs responsabilités explique à
partir de leurs malheurs je rappelle que
c'est la mort dans des conditions
tragiques de leur fille qui les a
bouleversés ont été amenés à monter
cette incroyables inexplicables complot
selon des sources proches de l'anc est
une commission rogatoire internationale
devrait être délivré à l'encontre d'un
troisième membre de la famille des
cherry parti précipitamment en algérie
en début de semaine la cour d'appel
confirme la condamnation de l'ancien
préfet bonnet la peine je vous le
rappelle était de 3 ans de prison dont
un ferme
bernard bonnet qui n'a passé que deux
mois en détention il n'était pas à
l'audience aujourd'hui mais il se
pourvoit en cassation à bastia caroline
since et eric chaney ils feront
retrouvent pour la dernière fois en
corse ce qui ont incendié sa paillote
ils sont tous là sauf un le préfet
bernard bonnet rester à paris avec ses
avocats
il ne voulait pas être jugé en corse et
il refuse aujourd'hui d'entendre sa
condamnation se laisse penser qu'il
avait peut-être quelques quelques idées
que neuf
la condamnation était était dans l'air
et c'est mon avis ça peut donner aussi
un sens ça donne un sens s'affaiblit en
quelque sorte le caractère solennel
décision qu'a rendue aujourd'hui en
audience publique avec toutes les
parties
le préfet est le plus lourdement
condamné à un an de prison ferme
assortie d'une privation de tous ses
droits civiques
il va se pourvoir en cassation ses
anciens amis le déteste aujourd'hui et
dénoncent les privilèges qui lui sont
accordés la page des pas près d'être
épuisé avec avec un bernard bonnet qui
est défendue aux frais du contribuable
que je le rappelle depuis une décision
au nom du ministre chevènement toutes
les peines ont été confirmés six mois
ferme pour gérard pardini le capitaine
embrasser le colonel mazères qui se
pourvoit en cassation
pour le colonel un seul objectif la
relaxe pour assurer son avenir
il est toujours devant moi c'est un mois
ferme épreuve
je compte prendre ma revanche je
m'entends professionnel mais je prendrai
ma revanche
les gendarmes du commando condamné à du
sursis veulent se tourner la page
tous ont perdu leurs illusions en corse
un seul a quitté la gendarmerie
mais cette affaire a laissé des traces
bien sûr ça reste donc oui ces raisons
et maintenant il faut fermer il faut
arrêter pour moi aujourd'hui j'espère
c'est la dernière fois que je vais me
représenter devant dans la justice le
jugement a été rendu dans la plus grande
indifférence du public corse
aucun des protagonistes condamnés me
rends en prison le feuilleton judiciaire
continue mais à paris devant la cour de
cassation
en corse la sphère des paillotes est bel
et bien terminée confirmation aussi pour
magali guillemot la cour de cassation a
rejeté son pourvoi aujourd'hui elle
avait été reconnue coupable de la mort
de son petit garçon lui ben est condamné
à dix ans de prison
son avocat envisage un recours en grâce
une famille de la métropole lilloise
vite un véritable enfer elle est
persécutée sans arrêt après que
l'adolescente et dénoncé une affaire de
viol collectif dont elle était victime
harcèlement insultes malgré un premier
déménagement
la situation ne fait qu'empirer sylvain
le kent depuis plusieurs jours
sarah ne sort pratiquement plus de chez
elle il y a un an
cette collégienne de 14 ans était
victime de plusieurs viols collectifs
les neuf agresseurs présumés ont été
arrêtés et mis en examen
mais depuis elle et sa famille subissent
des représailles de la part d'inconnus
bien qu'ils aient déménager pour un lieu
tenu secret ces jeunes qui viennent
jusque sur le palier j'ai trait sur les
murs m des feuilles
dans les escaliers sont fins et sky est
encore mal et menaces verbales puisque
moi les ai surpris en train de parler
entre eux puis six attrapés ma fille
banques et la lâchera pas que le père de
sarah porté plainte et des rondes de
police ont été organisées mais la
famille se prépare néanmoins à déménager
une seconde fois pour échapper à ces
intimidations envers les autres elle va
à l'école normalement c'est des copains
parce qu'on perd tous ses copains dès
qu'on aura un nouveau logement
on va pouvoir premier est normal et on a
des nouvelles âmes et puis après tout
ira bien dans quelques jours cinq des
agresseurs présumés tous mineurs vont
être libérés dans la tente du procès
prévu en fin d'année d'ici là la famille
de sarah espère avoir quitté le nord
pour retrouver un peu de sérénité
le débat se poursuit à l'assemblée
nationale à propos de la loi sur la
sécurité intérieure de nicolas sarkozy
malgré les protestations l'opposition le
texte passera à priori sans problème
il faut dire que l'ump bénéficient d'une
majorité absolue 365 députés un groupe
qui a pourtant des états d'âme et qui
aimerait bien les exprimer le
gouvernement y est très attentif en
première ligne jean-françois copé le
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement qui joue sans cesse les
démineurs daniel sportiello christian
welter pistonné c'est jean françois copé
qui le dit certains députés seraient
mieux servis que d'autres et parce qu'il
est difficile de partager équitablement
la galette
quand il y a 4 125 députés dans la
majorité certains au for cément des
états d'âme et le ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement doit tout
faire pour que ces états d'âme ne se
transforme pas en mauvaise humeur
on fait du cocooning dû parfois faut pas
non plus le single et la fatigue
l'énervement le stress à 2 heures du
matin dans enfin il ya des petites
explication de gravure bon ben on se dit
les choses ça va tout de suite ça m'a
tout de suite beaucoup mieux la séance
de cocooning la plus appréciée par les
parlementaires de la majorité c'est le
déjeuner à matignon avec les députés
jean françois copé c'est du sur-mesure
bats toi t'as pas trop de soucis dans le
jour
et quand le ministre s'affairent le
premier ministre lui-même confirme qu'au
gouvernement on prend très au sérieux le
malaise de certains députés y en a qui
est un moment espéré punis s'ils ne sont
pas à fait donc il faut être gentil avec
eux viennent à d'autres moments qui
voudraient tels rapports qui levait tel
amendement c'est pas toujours possible
donc il faut pouvoir gérer ça u n 9 ans
c'est ça la clé et même s'ils sont au
centre de toutes les attentions
certains députés en ont gros sur le
coeur quand on est dans la majorité
c'est ferme ta gueule et on va voir le
député on dit tu sais ton amendement il
est très très bien mais ce serait quand
même bien sûr pouvait le retirer parce
que on s'est tellement battu à matignon
pour avoir l'arbitrage et le faire et
c'est souvent vrai
donc voilà ce qui est ingrat je note
qu'un certain nombre de sujets de fond
ne sont pas bien traités
en particulier lorsqu'il ya eu la niche
parlementaire sur la pornographie la
télévision il est évident que ce soir on
a été bien gérée par le groupe en plus
de mécontentement c'est jean françois
copé qui fait tampon entre les
parlementaires et le gouvernement depuis
le mois de juin il est intervenu cinq
mille fois pour des problèmes de
trottoirs des demandes de décoration et
même des rendez vous pour les députés
dans un ministère
bref la routine alors on peut toujours
rêver ils se marièrent et lilou mais à
coup sûr le quotidien va vite le
rattraper
la sncf prévoit une nouvelle réduction
des effectifs de 1243 postes seraient
supprimés
ce sont les premières indications sur le
projet de budget 2003 alors que le
climat social est déjà tendue c'est la
fin d'une grande tradition la verrerie
de givors avait été créée par ordonnance
royale en 1749
elle a effectué sa dernière coulée la
nuit dernière un moment très émouvant
pour les salariés qui assistait à la
mort de leur usine qui sera d'ailleurs
détruites
valérie bonnet et pierre la chaussure
place lille et de l'ultime brigade du
matin une dizaine d'employés de
fabrication qui dans une usine
fonctionnant aux 5,8 prennent leur
service à 4 heures au milieu de la nuit
la verrerie crash ces derniers peau et
c'est eux qui seront en poste à l'heure
de l'arrêt définitif et par une meuleuse
ouais mais malheureusement vrai je le
savais pas mais c'est un peu dur mais
bon faut faire quoi mais par rapport au
t2 2010
j'ai récupéré tous mes bleus voilà tout
j'ai récupéré mes boulots aujourd'hui
ces derniers jours
ce devoir doit arrêter normalement
asesor
comment ça s'est passé ba aujourd'hui on
va arrêter le vous voulez faire c'est la
loi seul dans le local de la cgt ce
futur pré retraités se préparent aussi
au rendez vous vingt-deux mois de combat
syndical oblige son bleu ne sert plus
fier dans les grandes occasions
aujourd'hui c'est réservé projet savait
depuis 34 ans à 15 jours près voilà des
larmes aux yeux
les verriers de givors ne sont pas
chargés de la mission douloureuse c'est
une entreprise extérieure sans état
d'âme qui prend position pour la percée
du faux seins l'enfiler de verre en
fusion la soupe comme il l'appelle sort
du ventre de briques presque 400 tonnes
de matière à vider
l'opération est prévue sur 24 à 36
heures le ver réduit en poudre sera
expédié dans une autre vers reid hugo
bsn le four numéro 8 lui mettra
peut-être une semaine à se refroidir
mais tout est déjà finie restera s'est
terminée il ya plus de production et
c'est l'impunité
nouveau paysage de cauchemar en galice
de nouvelles nappes sont arrivés sur les
côtes espagnoles deux mois après le
naufrage du prestige
d'après une première estimation le
nettoyage coûtera un milliard d'euros à
l'espagne
en france les pêcheurs du bassin
d'arcachon ont déversé deux tonnes de
fuel devant les affaires maritimes cet
après midi ils protestent contre
l'absence de garanties écrites
d'indemnisation de l'état 12 tonnes de
fuel aurait été ramassés ce matin au
niveau de la dune du pilat ludivine
tachon jean-michel litvine
mais le gros coup de colère des pêcheurs
du bassin d'arcachon devant les affaires
maritimes cet après midi depuis dix
jours maintenant une sorte leur bateau
pour les ramasser le fuel et ils ont
encore récolté 10 tonnes ce matin en
l'espace de deux heures
mais voilà depuis qu'ils ne peuvent plus
pêcher la palourde et que leurs bateaux
sont réquisitionnés les marins pêcheurs
n'ont reçu aucune indemnisation blanc
croit savoir le bon rencontrer les
citoyens aujourd'hui ça me dit
rencontrer le préfet qui doit avoir des
réponses concrètes pour lundi on est
mercredi avoir toujours hier pas ainsi
et eux non plus ce rémois se désole
c'est vrai que je montrais emmerder les
préfets les sous-préfets men ou encore
plus ils sont 75 à vivre exclusivement
de la pêche sur le bassin 75 à ne pas
toucher 1 euros alors que le ramassage
du scion se fait à leurs frais pour un
oiseau il donne douze mille francs nous
on n'a même pas 20 de femmes par jour
c'est inadmissible c'est pour ça que on
va mettre un petit peu le bordel
parce que c'est peut-être même pas la
solution mais il faut qu'on fasse
quelque chose parce qu'autrement
aujourd'hui les pêcheurs sont à bout et
demandent une indemnisation journalière
de 150 euros par hommes et 450 euros par
bateau si la situation n'évolue pas ils
refuseront désormais de remplacer les
palourdes dans leurs filets par les
galettes d'hydrocarbure tous les moyens
qui sont mises en oeuvre de la bretagne
au pays basque pour lutter contre la
marée noire sont sous la responsabilité
d'un seul homme
le préfet maritime de l'atlantique il
gère 70% de la pêche française
un tiers du tourisme et la moitié de la
plaisance il est aujourd'hui sur tous
les fronts portrait signé pierre babey
et civils vont vers deux seules côtes et
béret basque sur ses pontons c'est un
marin presque ordinaire presque parce
qu'ici à brest c'est le préfet maritime
préfet maritime c'est à dire chefs
militaires mais surtout responsable de
tout ce qui se passe en mer du mont
saint michel à la frontière espagnole
le naufrage du prestige c'est pour lui
la lutte contre la pollution la
coordination des moyens européens c'est
lui c'est sa bataille il la mène tambour
battant depuis la préfecture maritime de
brest
la recette à la française c'est ça c'est
de mettre sous une même casquette les
responsabilités militaires qui font que
l'ensemble des moyens de la marine
nationale très important pour l'action
de l'état en mer sont immédiatement à
disposition du préfet maritime
il ya donc pas de conflit entre l'amiral
qui commande les forces l'atlantique et
le préfet maritime puisque c'est le même
c'était une grande facilité en dehors
des crises comme le prestige six
carrières futures postulent pour ton
post 1 il y a le quotidien dans la zone
maritime la plus exposées d'europe ici
sur le rail d'ouessant passe 150 navires
et surtout sept cent mille tonnes
d'hydrocarbures par jour et sur les 2500
km de responsabilité de l'amiral il y a
cinq mille interventions par an au
profit de tous les marins sans
distinction civile militaire amateurs
professionnels maritimes ça veut dire
préfet de tous les marins de la mer ça
veut dire en fait ma clientèle est assez
largement représentés ici au moins en
matière de sécurité en mer puisque on a
deux sortes de type d'activité on à
l'hiver où notre principal souci sans
les marins du commerce et les marins
pêcheurs et elle était où le principal
souci c'est les plaisanciers
mais pour l'instant le principal souci
reste donc le prestige sa pollution
ces retombées politiques ces retombées
médiatiques et si par malheur la côte
française étaient souillés comme la
galice le préfet maritime passerait la
main à ses collègues territoriaux mais
pour l'instant l'amiral est sur le pont
24 heures sur 24
à peine at il le temps de lever le nez
au départ du trophée jules verne pour me
moquer d'eux hors bateaux de kersauson
évidemment il n'est pas sous mes ordres
mais rien de ce qu'ils naviguent nommé à
différents et en plus olivier est un
copain mais kersauson est quand même
sous leur responsabilité de l'amiral gar
30 puisque depuis brest sa zone
atlantique cours du pôle nord jusqu'au
cap horn
une autre pollution est apparu cette
fois au large de boulogne sur mer près
du cap gris nez
il s'agit d'une nappe de 4 kilomètres
des analyses sont en cours pour savoir
si elle provient d'un déballastage
sauvage sports décidément les filles
sont au plus haut niveau dans le ski
français en snowboard isabelle blanc et
karine ruby ont respectivement décroché
la médaille d'or et la médaille d'argent
lors du slalom parallèle aux
championnats du monde
iceberg en autriche et puis très belle
victoire aussi pour carole montillet qui
a remporté le super g de cortina
d'ampezzo comptant pour la coupe du
monde
c'est sur cette piste il y a deux ans
jour pour jour son ami régine cavagnoud
s'était imposé en descente
mathieu méranville carole montillet
heureuse et émue et mis à la pensée de
régine cavagnoud décédé en 2001
heureuse de l'emporter ici comme
cavalier il y a deux ans alors quand
elle s'élance sur la piste de cortina
d'ampezzo
la française est plus décidé que jamais
montillet a comme temps de référence
celui de renate goetschl l'autrichienne
véritable spécialiste du super g elles
font tous les risques techniques rapides
à la rivale la fille de villard de lans
l'emportent avec une demi seconde
d'avancé sur google
l'année commence bien pour carole
montillet qui signe là sa troisième
victoire de la saison
cinéma vous avez peut-être vu les très
beaux dessins animés le voyage de
chihiro et la princesse mononoké du
réalisateur japonais miyazaki son
premier film était inédit en france 15
ans après il sort sur les écrans
enfin richard tripot m'appelle chypre à
wichita c'est jules commun mais alors
comment tu as fait comment est-ce que tu
tombé du ciel
une petite fille prénommée gîte a
descendu du ciel un petit garçon
orphelin qui travaillent dans la mine la
rencontre de ses deux enfants c'est
celle de deux mondes se du ciel et de la
terre avec un secret apportée par
cheetah tout là-haut derrière les nuages
il y à un château une forteresse
convoité par des puissances maléfiques
il est à ma famille depuis des
générations dans cet univers fantastique
cher au réalisateur japonais
cheetah est plutôt vont s'envoler vers
les étoiles vaincre les forces du mal et
bien sûr retrouver le château perdu
réalisé dans les studios de tokyo les
histoires et les dessins de miyazaki
sont inspirés par des auteurs européens
comme dickens swift ou jules verne mais
aussi par ses propres voyages au cours
d'un voyage d'une promenade il ya des
choses qui me frappe et je me dis
maintien
je les utiliserai bien la prochaine fois
du coup de mon prochain film il y aura
des paysages de patagonie et le
kazakhstan
l'univers de miyazaki est telle qu'un
véritable musée lui est désormais
consacrée à mithaq à près de tokyo un
endroit où les enfants peuvent retrouver
les personnages de shiro mononoké totoro
et autres robots comme celui-ci issus de
son dernier film quand j'étais jeune je
voulais être philosophe parce que
j'étais préoccupé par tous les problèmes
du monde mais en voyant ma tête je me
suis dit que j'avais plutôt l'air réjoui
alors j'ai abandonné
cet amour de la philosophie miyazaki la
mise en service de la beauté de ses
films avec un scénario d'une grande
richesse
l'alternance d'action et de repos
d'humour et de gravité
ce château dans le ciel nous fait rêver
et réfléchir tout de suite les titres de
votre région la météo complète de
jean-marc swami prochain rendez vous
avec la rédaction 22h50 soir 3 laurence
bobillier excellente soirée merci
bonsoir